Here's another question for you.
Suppose you have a model where you very carefully tuned it to minimize,
say the sum of squared errors on a regression.
And, let's say that in order to minimize the sum of squared errors,
you found yourself very carefully tuning the parameters, and also using lots and
lots of features to try to get every little bit of
information out of the data that you could.
Maybe you're using all the features that you could even think of,
which could potentially be dozens.
In this situation, do you think you should be more worried about the variance of
your model, or the bias?
Click which one you think is right.